you're honest about what you've done you
said I got when did you get breast
implants was that high school well no
that was last January so it's been like
a little over a year and you were clear
you documented you said hey I don't want
to put it out there to other girls who
are watching this I know it looks like
you know hey I look good and all this
but at the same point you got to be
really careful putting something into
your body blah blah blah you gave all
the disclaimers but then you take people
through getting them yeah and why you
just want to look better in the clothes
I mean it's just something a personal
choice and I think if there's something
you want to do for yourself then do it
but I would never go on the internet and
lie or not say something if someone says
oh you got that done like yes I did
because you grow up and I've grown up
watching people on social media and
they're like oh this is just how I was
born this is how I look and I'm like
well like I don't look like that
and it's just not real was it a big
change when you got your boobs did you
um uh did you go from like an A cup to a
d a d or something about yeah that's a
big deal it is yeah and and your dog a
minute why not it's good if you keep
stuff secret yeah you probably won't
have a big following is that the key and
that's like what are you really gonna
lie about that like oh yeah they just
grew overnight no right I'm gonna keep
them wrong and you said you wheeled into
the room they wheeled you into the room
you were fine about it but then you saw
the lineup of knives oh it's not fun
like that they don't warn you for that
like you are sitting there in this cold
refrigerated room you feel like a piece
of meat in there like you see the knives
and they're like oh you had to like just
chill here for a second and I'm like
wait like knock me out like I can't be
sitting here seeing this and and as a
kid you took supplements hoping to grow
your breasts oh yeah that didn't work I
was like oh these like little Gummy
Bears whatever I would see online I'm
like yeah this will be this will be
great this is the one trusty gummy bears
do not make you yeah I've heard
different types of like milk and stuff I
was like yeah I was trying all I was
like you know what we're just gonna have
to dish it out here
thank you